there is so much confidence that comes
with actual skill and I had a year and a
half to actually learn how to box whose
[__] idea was it to give me this much
time to become an athlete I'm the
biggest pop cost in the world wow this
is gonna be a [__] show let's just go
with it speaking of [__] show George it
really did seem like a shitty situation
I didn't know if you were gonna feel
crappy about it how did you pull
yourself out of the dumps I love you but
I [__] hate Jordi all this is that
Jacob married man is this the real deal
yeah a hundred percent I mean I think
you're really telling me as a video
career but I think you're going down a
road that's like [__] I was just
getting to know you and you I like that
hey Jordy man I'd love to stay and talk
to you but I haven't [__] this girl in
two months my coach says sex is a
misdemeanor the more you miss the meaner
you get I broke it like two days before
the fight oh I've never been hornier in
my life I was like ah messed me up in
the fight for sure
everyday we sit down his face is [__]
read you just sparred and he's ready to
[__] kill someone November 9th now is
the only day in my life that matters
there are no distractions
none I'm not doing anything that I did
last fight to prepare for this fight you
know I last fight I didn't win I'm a BJJ
I'm gonna do my first fight in the UFC
I'm gonna win on a smoke this [__]
dude whoever it is my goal is to be
bigger than the rock
[Music]
we're fresh off the part of the London
press conference with Logan Paul Jake
was there might you were watching from
the side do you feel like you won that
Logan first off I gotta say I'm happy to
be back
you've loved yeah this is it impulsive
meets true Jodi I love it
incredible you know this place is
beautiful I was gonna tell you on your
shots will look looking more crisp now
what are you shooting in 4k then yeah
yes shout out to my boys I've got an
amazing team awesome far more
intelligent than me
I see I'm the biggest podcast in the
world Wow Wow it's not as cool as this
dude we have one cameraman he's right
there the vegan kid with my he's great
buddy damn dude you guys got little
[__] rails and [__] the movements
pretty oh my god we got a guy owns he
does freehand as well where's I feel
like the interruptions might be omit
this is going to be a [__] show let's
just go with it okay
speaking of [__] show Jordan
can we just do half an hour before all
right oh that's all bro I just go Geordi
I haven't seen you for a minute and all
the sudden I find out my guys are free
yeah I mean wow this is a weird thing go
that wasn't even like the thing like I
don't know about you but sometimes I use
like messages as a form of porn so I
might be like one day I might be saying
one thing I'm positive you know I have
nothing in common when it comes to
sexuality and I feel sorry for you
because I'm having the time of my life
from you know you and I you it's your
obligation to take advantage of what God
has given you in life and I'm just doing
yeah if you get famous and you don't
take advantage of that you're a [__]
[__]
I'm not good on the [__] this when I'm
50 years old and say well I was a good
boy and I stuck with one girl like the
sidemen did no I'm not I'm telling you
know no offense like well you know soon
so I do because my best friend Mike is
very eerily similar this is why not when
I saw that [__] dude I was saying to
myself this man is a freak freak a nice
so you actually recognized it and on the
podcast radio you'e like I've got my
card I'm like totally with him on this
now as I always will Ryan Recker those
freaks why be ashamed of it bro you were
in LA that kind of stuff is highly
supported there we got a whole industry
man I don't know 22 message me he goes
dude like if you're not you if she's
legal this is not even on the radar
another Road you don't Adam 22 literally
[__] on camera yeah out of 22 but he's
like podcasting we're taking podcasting
down basically we're calling it porn
casimiro Gonzaga now psych for [__]
sake and you know how know that you're
oaken's looking
but yo ya know you're right you owned it
which I we were all curious to see like
what you would do because that was your
first I don't want to say like you
didn't get like cancel per se but you
there's definitely an ounce of me for
sure okay but they don't know what I've
been through my life and I've been
through way more than a [__] dirty
message and the only people surprised by
that well the people who don't watch me
weekend week now cuz I'll be making
dirty jokes for four years and saying I
wanna [__] girls in the ass for four
years now so is this is surprisingly you
the by the ways the way you handled it
was the biggest they did great you've
had your we've all had it and literally
for me a delicious you a lot of [__] can
I ask you a question though and let's
talk about the press conference but I
wanted to ask you a question man-to-man
are did that affect you at all and your
demeanor your energy and your mental
health at all well you know what I felt
right this is the honest truth you came
into my head and I thought [__] me like
I'm trending on Twitter because of my
sex life like this is crazy people are
actually caring about how I want to [__]
a woman or not even just I want a
message a woman I mean so I thought
myself like when so many people come out
because obviously the mess like
depending on what mood I'm in sometimes
I might be dominant sometimes I might be
so Mis I'm a switch yeah so and those
messages were quite submissive probably
not what people would expect from me so
therefore the tomato like whoa
but people to make such a big deal about
it I just thought the level of strength
that you muster hard to get what [__]
you went through because mine was like
nothing compared to what you have I just
saw actually I now say things from a
better perspective ah so I had I did
think about you and I thought and
everyone who goes through this [__] it's
such [__] like the internet isn't
real this isn't real people's opinions
of me aren't real you're right it's all
[__] you're right but I wanted to
ask I guess on their other question a
little more it's funny because like a
policy you're such a podcast
feels like impulsive this is great huh
when you walk around in public are you
afraid of people saying like yo you're a
freak George or D like your weirdo well
you know what it is right
frog my senior is I've you know I've got
I've got wounds to prove what I'm
capable of
so if people want to do that then let's
let's see what this doesn't happen were
you nervous today I don't know about any
of it no not for that I was nervous
because I didn't want to do a bad job
but I wasn't thinking about that because
like in my head it's like I don't know I
never even considered that I just wonder
if is subconsciously you're thinking
about how people perceive you and if
that's affecting the way you're moving
forward no less now in the media week I
think would be weird if I didn't think
how are people gonna look at maybe fear
I want to be respected incredible when I
work like I want people to think I got
sick podcast when people think they're
true Jordy I want people think sick
podcast funny guy you know does the the
press conference as well interviews well
I think he wants girls - it's not yeah I
mean I take this with a grain of salt
but in my opinion you made it cool like
I love you more now I just nothing I
like more than authenticity yeah that
you could double down I was yeah
how do you it really did seem like a
shitty situation I didn't I didn't know
if you were gonna feel crappy about it
how did you pull yourself out of the
dumps I love you bye [__] Hey not
that weak I I drunk and I smoked a
shitload miles I I'm just gonna [__] out
in this right now so I'm here but I'm
not here June and I mean is it ironic
how they tell you not to exact times of
just right so that is same by the way
and I'm like this is great I'm not
present at all I'm not present for the
next year I'm here in body but in mind
I'll check that I'm on holiday right now
I catch you next Friday
so but you know people that opinions of
you can't hide it you call
let people's opinions of you [__]
develop I knew and at that moment it
felt [__] but I was like you know it is
annoying I'm annoyed by any word that
has anything do one which is radio
annoying
have you learned on it have you learned
how to like completely push the opinions
of others out of your ear like care
factor like from a teenager I've never
given a [__] what anyone so this is
nothing new to me it's just a case of
really real so it's one thing saying I
don't give a [__] about any one things
we all like to say that but right but
only when you when you only when your
name becomes a joke like you have like
I've had like other people have had do
you really have to [__] prove that
you don't give a [__] I have told this
to Mike a countless number of times
because my man I don't know if you've
noticed Mike don't give many [__] much
less than me and much less than I ever
did and and he's authentic and he that's
Mike in real life he's just like a
genuine guy in his imma do me and if you
don't like it [__] off zone but when you
come under fire for doing something and
it affects who you think you are who you
think you might be or what you can
become you start to shell up a little
bit and it's tough because that's why I
commend you for doubling down because I
mean now I mean I I'm assuming your you
you're never gonna make a mistake but
now it's gonna be tough to attack your
character knowing that like you truly
don't give off hell yeah you didn't a
pot you never made an apology right now
that's quite deliberate right that's it
that's the thing I think it's in this
day and age as soon as you apologize you
lose because that's when they turn the
[__] heat on how much people love to
see the downfall of an online
personality they [__] the easier life
yes the culture is like the biggest
thing like because people there's some
like misery loves company and there's so
much jealousy and hate out in the world
and so on someone who they've seen
succeed like makes a mistake
people love to rip them back down you
got it on whatever you are in this life
and that's what I do good [__] we don't
do
we don't do dirty DMS I won't do it I
was gonna ask don't do them that was any
more dirty nein but James once or twice
yeah I got caught once or twice now is
junk boy times when I was sending them
though right there you go what did you
do
oh she was [__] hot I was like we got
to give him up even if she's in a
relationship jail no because if you're
in a relationship and she thought he was
a model from the UK he was going to
flyer oh wow sorry about just no news be
pulled out so many controversy I was
just like yeah like I was like I bribed
broken up with my girlfriend like
temporarily and I saw I started damning
girls and then she put it all over the
internet oh yeah and she was down to fly
out still after that don't look like it
was like she was still like oh okay
cause the end it was a ten you have
every right sorry what I know but I can
relate because for some reason after
Japan I felt super like lonely like a
really really existential sense of like
loneliness and so I started DMing models
I got in like yeah like bride damn like
15 and like one of them tweeted it and
then like a fact and it went viral and I
got called out because she had a
boyfriend and it was all that bad stuff
and I don't know I don't know what
sometimes you do it B could for like a
attention or what and I've told this
story before but I mean she ugly now so
I think I won I think I won that battle
your situation scared the [__] out of me
quite literally
I don't even do that I'm [__] purpose
man so look at this girl this girl hit
me up you're fit is kind of turning me
on and I said suits in a short is a vibe
and she said you could say my mouth is a
vibe that was her response clip that I
saw that I was like if I respond to this
with what are you doing come through or
some [__]
I'm gonna get exponent how do you define
vibe we're supposed to chase women when
we get into a position in life where men
have women just thrown themselves on
them like we're how does that nudie
you've had that out of me not on the
[__] level we're a million people are
watching your [__] and then the
edges like so let's think about when I
was 18
I'm going to a nightclub there's a
hundred people in there 50 of them are
women maybe three of them want to [__]
me maybe two of them are in
relationships already so that leaves one
woman if I'm lucky I'm going to pop in
this bomb times 100 by a thousand or
10,000 yes that's weekly now you got
that chain you also spelled my 90k in
the neck the way I notice when I was in
the bathroom you had a lot of
moisturizer and I actually took a
picture because I've never sick it these
are all go these are all different
brands oh I'm just oh you have so much
more I've gotta look after myself do you
know what do you I mean if you're a big
guy I know but exactly that's like
that's like one body let me use your
personal bathroom
I am I had a go Jordi trust me yeah and
then I saw the moisturizer I don't I
don't trust me I'm really glad you
didn't look in the other company mooster
eyes are over right by the sink there
wasn't even so look you've just got this
[__] press conference
all right you've just done the press
conference didn't soap his hands how do
you feel now when you're when you
actually let's take this back okay the
night of the fight the last time I seen
you guys [__] me was at that nightclub
yeah we went to the after-party
you know everyone you were in good mood
you you had your bell everything was
great yeah I mean what did it feel like
when you actually got home and you
realized [__] I drew like what was that
actually like in a way it was almost as
depressing as the defeat would have been
like I feel like because six months of
hard work in three months of boxing
training was for nothing or so it felt
but I found out that the foundation that
we had built was such a strong
foundation that contributed to my boxing
ability now and it was so necessary and
I think I think from a macro perspective
me not losing
was a big win-win because that whole
year was losses everything that I did
was an L a phat L that I took to the
chin
and I wasn't used to failing
repetitively that grand ever and so the
draw to me was a win because it didn't
give everyone the opportunity that they
really wanted which was to can't evoke
and Paul for forever by the way because
if I if I had lost I think I mean like
what am i joking that enough in our
first two rows I'm ringside I'm used to
because JJ was Joe he he was in his head
Joe was noticeably like shot going the
erroring with you the confidence you had
for that for the first fight yeah I was
like wow and when you were laughing at
him and jabbing is like that off I was
like holy SH you can you say something
for us really quick I've been dying to
hear this again since last four anyway
you could say the following sentence Oh
JJ I remember talking to Jake after in
the after party in Jake when you know
the modest thing he only learned how a
boxer properly two weeks ago I was like
oh [__] I watch every single sparring
and and I would like sit there and like
try to tell Logan what to do and like I
feel like Logan's does have a person
where it's either like a hundred percent
like he's getting it or like not and
like two weeks before the fight I was
like this is the first sparring session
where like I saw him like move like a
boxer and then like ten days later was
our last sparring session and then all
of a sudden they're fighting so it's
like now this year is like completely
different that's that's why I mean I
think you you could probably notice it I
just I'm walking around with a lot more
confidence like my chest is puffed out a
little more my Chin's a little higher
when you look [__] huge like when I
seen you did I was like Jesus thank you
go massive yeah I just I mean it's I'm
not gonna try to play the tough-guy role
here like I do sometimes with Jay Jay
like when I'm like I'm gonna knock you
out around 2 it's just like there is so
much confidence that comes with actual
skill
and I had a year-and-a-half to actually
learn how to box whose [__] idea was
it to give me this much time to become
an athlete hmm do you know when you seen
JJ going on - uh were you training that
whole time the whole time I go he goes
he not he announced his tour I got yo
time to [__] eat this is it man's
man's gonna be eating fast food
he's gonna be unhealthy is gonna be on
tour not sleeping maybe drinking smoking
and I'm gonna be waking up at 8:00 a.m.
training every single day because
November 9th now is the only day in my
life that matters that's it you put it
on - uh what's not life like yeah I was
actually I was I went on tour what after
the mine and Eddie's fight was confirmed
so I was training on tour but yeah
they're still drinking they're still
smoking there's long nights you're
sleeping like on a bus like this like
you're back you wake up your backs or
like you have to exert so much energy to
the crowd so like even if he was
training during that time it's like
they're like shitty training sessions
you have to find a random gym in some
random City and hope there's a sparring
partner there the food is shitty like
it's the worst it was the worst thing it
was really really difficult to do well
one of the things you said to me on that
night like cuz I I was just getting to
know you
there's a guy that we've kept in touch
quite yet since then but you know when
someone says something you're like he's
like he's like my kind of guy
you were like hey Jordy this was like
foria man I'd love to stay and talk to
you but I'm [__] this girl in two
months soft with Chloe [__] penny and
I was like you know what as if you tell
me you don't want to talk to me because
you want to go [__] a girl you are my
kind of I like that it was my girlfriend
and we heard this rumor that if you
don't have sex 30 days before your fight
it like builds up your testosterone or
something and it makes you angrier my
coach says sex is a misdemeanor the more
you misdemeanor you get and yeah I don't
know well you're still my honest about
having sex right now
so not supposed to at all well the thing
about that is doesn't [__] that because
nah bro Briggs
Briggs is gonna listen to this here's
gonna be a big [__] no here's the deal
here at Briggs listen please hear me out
these are he's an intimidating guns you
know when phrases every morning going yo
you not last night champ I'm like no no
yeah and he's like you can't be none you
build your batch I'm like build your
batch King batch I'll go a listen the
theory is I'm not doing anything that I
did last fight to prepare for this fight
you know why cuz last fight I didn't win
so why would I repeat any of the [__] I
did changing it up brother
well you changed from Milton more to use
Milton still involved or is the mill is
evolved he's he's there every day
yeah it's Shannon just became the head
coach and what Milton's like he's not
even an assistant coach it's like a Cole
coaching thing we ask you about Shannon
bankers like people who split on him
people are split and I've only ever seen
him say a handful of sentences and I
mean this like in the most respectful
way and any one in specific that stands
out not spring the my visit Lawrence
maybe to other people i I think he comes
across badly in public but in private he
seems like a different kind of carrot so
his podcast with Joe Rogan he came
across amazingly but then on stage from
naturally it's hard to come across well
on stage but he just comes across as a
guy dressed well gives a [__] how across
my ass here's my ass 36
I think 36 first-round knockout so like
at the end of the day like he doesn't
say a lot of words right here's what I'm
saying I'm construct my question
basically into what does he don't see
listen bro look at me in many ways am I
not the same way in many ways when I'm
vlogging or on stage I act and look
sometimes like a [__] [__] and like
bro go on fox business and tell them I
have pink eye on fox business did you
see that by chance yes look that was one
of the funniest things well as you well
cuz you know I'm [__] around
Oh everyone's like yo this kids an idiot
easy roll cane or I'm just [__]
around but on a podcast I can speak at
length about things
Shannon is smart as [__] and I'm not
saying that because
my coach I'm saying that because the
amount of time that I've spent with him
where I get to like understand how his
brain works it's fascinating
time and time again I go this is why
he's the world champ right he just
understands like everything it's just
that you know in public let's go champ
is his thing and I'm sure he doesn't
have a forum to exhibit his intelligence
what why do you think it doesn't come
out in public when it's clearly so
evident to a lot of people privately
because he is clearly a strong man like
he's clearly he's not something you're
like what are you going to say on stage
where to go Sam I'm trying to understand
like what what what are you gonna say I
stand what are you gonna say on stage
when there's like 3,000 kids going suck
your mom suck your mom like you can't
look intelligent you don't know saying
like it's exactly what Logan saying it's
like long form versus short form form I
would say this everyone has modes I got
I got my podcast mode I got my personal
mode I got the vlog mode he's got my
phone I got it I got me in training mode
Shannon has his like personal mode he's
got his I'm on stage hype mode and that
comes across as let's go champ let's go
like that's his height mode and even me
why a camera I'm gonna relate to that is
because like let's take two examples
right now LA press conference today's
press conference LA press conference
y'all you're a [__] [__] where's
your brother just like kind of being a
bully hype like angry today everyone was
having fun like kind of chill it's
chilling I like it making some of the
simple jokes like if fella you prepared
with a mood that's what Lauren's said
before that he was like if I like you
constructed this whole thing where you
were like I know what's gonna come and
I'm ready for it this time it's not true
absolutely and I want to give a shout
out to Andre actually actually because
um I I encourage people in my camp to
not be yes-men and I think I mean the
crew I have around me right now is so
strong and Andre as we were talking
about my demeanor my attitude my
character for this press conference we
were going through some of the lines I
might say he goes yo is there any way
you could say it without sounding so
childish and the van kind of got silent
and everyone kind of looked around cuz
like you know like Loki Loki just
insulted the boss and I'm like
yo that's [__] tight you're absolutely
right and and Mike's like no no I'm like
no no he's got a point like what if I
could what if I can go up there and talk
as if I'm on a podcast cool calm
collected couth suave swag how many say
you write not for Soros [__] hey bro I
know words and I love words yeah but I
have to give a shout-out to Andre cuz
even like before the press conference
like he tapped me bill yo podcast about
podcast I said headphones on you yeah
yeah you pull out like but that was Jake
my boys are done I said for now
currently letting me look like a [__]
and cuz like similar to Shannon my
height mode when I grab the mic start
screaming that's it bro and it doesn't
come across that well but the podcast
version of LP is a little more likeable
without actually work because but I also
thought that you've lost the first press
conference it's been very much but I
thought you did much better in this
press conference thanks man but um it
was totally different I don't know what
you what did you guys think I thought I
mean if you look at his body language in
both of them I think he took both of
them but at tonight like listen JD is
sitting down
Logan's standing over him establishing
clear dominance JJ's not making any
moves he's not standing up
Logan's relaxed he's keeping his comedic
approach that trolling approach that
we've seen him do before on Fox News and
other podcasts whatever and I mean
listen like he was ready for whatever JJ
brought out he brought out a dog he had
dog treats for him you know like before
happened I I would make a change
he'd they were for JJ yeah now the kids
predictable bro like I I go well what
would I maybe do I'd maybe bring out a
dog why I wouldn't have if I was JJ is
just because I am terrified of PETA and
I swear to God I saw this dog shaking
I'm like this ain't great I think I even
said it I was like that ain't great just
cuz the dog looked terrified and I
wouldn't look like Kong I wouldn't he
doesn't even look like but um yeah I
brought dog treats I was like yo like
you're predictable by the way here's the
dog free and he hit it out of my hammer
I didn't even get the majority right now
looking at these two guys or your friend
when you're friends with your
I mean don't even ask is there is there
a very clear is there not a clear
thought in your mind as to how this
fight is gonna go down I mean come on
don't don't know I found that the first
fight is an indicator in itself because
especially because you're getting
trained by Shannon Lee the the power and
also I think you've got the physical
advantages over this guy your longer
reach clearly a stronger man clearly and
the early rounds if you're gonna put
money on it you put the early rounds on
Logan but to be fair to JJ and I say
this JJ has this like freaky stamina
he's got weird stamina like the the guy
he can run and run and run it's it's
just weird
especially for his weight so lay around
most people are gonna say but they did
think it would go the same way as the
first fight that being said you've been
training a lot longer now we could be
seeing a totally different globe and
Paul I'm a totally different JJ so I'm
just keeping an open mind general I mean
it's scary that I mean when we first we
saw you downstairs and what was I like
when I see him Logan when we went back
at the dress the dress probably it's a
dressing room he just sat down and went
[__] knees huge sigh wow he's like me
but without the [__] I don't know why
but last time I know as we'd say is you
didn't seem as tall you didn't seem as
big and then this time when you two were
chatting I was like wow you're as big as
yours widest Bryan and you're is almost
as tall as Bryan and I guess there's a
different presence I don't know if you
guys have noticed it cuz it's been like
a gradual thing but it's a kind it's
it's mostly in his confidence you know
what I'm saying I mean like like Jake
said last time before the fight he had
just finished up learning how to [__]
box two weeks earlier you know what I'm
saying or like a month earlier right now
he's been boxing in fight mode for a
year sorry I can't drink let's hope cuz
we got loads of [__] mics we've been
sober for a minute Mike's doing it with
me 60 days I had some girl the other day
I was at the club and she was telling me
that it could all be mine if I could
just take a shot
and I was like can you [__] stop I
was like I can't do and they're like why
are you not drinking for someone else's
fight I was like because that's the
other thing like there's been a lot of
this like there's been a lot of talk
between the Seidman and on our camp on
this one and between JJ and our camp and
like a lot of back and forth on the
podcast and this and that and like
obviously I've never met any of them I
don't have any any issues with them but
like they've called me a yes meant so
many times in like he could Hilton bro
like they call a walking talking yes bro
the amount of times me and him fight on
a daily basis about [__] like I'm the I
am the only person who tells him
absolutely [__] not however if know
that I hate Mike literally I know do you
know many times I've to go it's amazing
out here Elyse similar a relationship
yeah I guess like I also get sick of
hearing like oh you brines [__] or
whatever when it's clearly like we're
our own people and if anything like
would they really be in the positions
they're in with our city yeah I mean
like like he like he couldn't have
[__] girls over and sort of blow your
cover but he had a girl over the other
day and I went upstairs and I said and I
said and I said you have to [__]
leave before the fight cam gets here and
he was like I said get up get your [__]
and get the [__] out before Shannon
Briggs comes here and everybody's in
[__] trouble
and so like I have to be that guy that
[__] does [__] that he doesn't want
me to do
yeah I'm saying so going back to girls
oh sure when when when I met Chloe Chloe
Bennet I was sort of taken aback by her
I've never met anyone like her she said
to me about the podcast that we did like
that was really great so special like
that she just had a way about her and I
thought in my head this is the [__]
girl this guy needs to stick with she's
gonna be the best thing for him so when
when he split with that girl I was like
oh [__] like as a friend you know um I
don't want to know that fully ins and
outs and that but like how was it being
going from you seem in like this is the
best thing and then all of a sudden it's
a great question
Chloe's the gem that girl is one of a
kind she's what we call a unicorn like
one of one she just had a movie that
came out it's called abominable coat
check it out
laughs folks I got you close but uh if
I'm you office do you love - oh yeah I'm
sure you still do by the way so did I we
FaceTime from time to time she's a
friend now and I can say that without
feeling like there's strings attached or
anything more than just like pure
unconditional love and friendship like
and I'm blessed to be able to have a
boss and like her in my life yeah but um
I will say no offense to Chloe I will
say being single this fight I've noticed
is it is so crucial and important and I
love every second of it because all like
all I can do is focus tunnel vision
Tunnel [__] vision bro there are no
distractions
none and last year I remember it was it
being hard to balance this relationship
and this this this fight because bro
like these guys will tell you when I'm
in training camp especially after
sparring sessions yo my testosterone is
raging I am I am a bull in a china shop
off piste
I just napped on Danny a couple times
like my assistant like everyone the
house is just like yo like Mike tells me
the other day he's like yo Kiwi just
please like after this fight after you
beat the [__] out of this cake we like
please not talk about fighting for like
too much like think about us how like
light hearted we are and we sit on the
podcast every day and we sit down we
totally make dick jokes we have a great
time we just make people laugh and right
now dude every - every day we're serious
in it oh it's fun yeah well every day we
sit down his face is [__] red he just
sparred and he's ready to [__] kill
somebody bro all he wants to do is just
eat dude that's it
I had to as well didn't you and Chloe
didn't you guys hook up like a couple of
days before the fight as well no no no
no because Shannon no million+
he held on positive you have certain
mother on the night in the nightclubs I
love this girl yeah well remember I
remember also because Erica was dating
Jake at the time came around the same
time Chloe came and Jake came
like like like literally [__] my
brother love him I broke it like two
days before the fight oh I've never been
hornier in my life I was like I remember
I was so disappointed disappointed in
him I think it yeah I think it messed me
up in the fight for sure but it's a
whole new way finished edgy two roads
early well why'd you break well I
couldn't control myself
like I've never like been like had that
much like I call it fiending yeah like
grabs her and I like was like I like
threw her and like I was like
surrounding a bed and like I was like oh
it's true door to my survival a look
into because that sounds terrible Jordie
all this is [__] that Jacob married man
Congrats in you it is all true a lot of
people are still question like what is
this real we were skeptical what
festival Anya is this the real deal yeah
a hundred or so I mean I'm not saying
that I'm like the best [__] spotter
in my life but like you see what she
have you have you ever gone shopping
with you with a girl before
ticket hummus I really hope is that what
we sit with what why are you asking like
that's where the bar is where you're at
in life though you want to get hummus is
that I'm married and we go shopping for
hummus and carrots what kind of home is
just straight up like just straight up
lemon and coriander special I keep
seeing tweets about like she's not on
birth control anymore we're trying like
yeah that's what I mean you're
triggering people life right and center
yeah at in the dammit role how far is
this gonna go though
amateur all and or married row this
point Lee this could go too far do you
know I mean she's not part of the trade
blood
you kill someone for me getting to a
point where no one knows what's true and
what's not true I think I'm at that
point yeah I'm sorry right now like no
i'm vladimir putin yeah i mean i was at
the wedding by the way I saw it go down
it and by the way it was it was the
wedding was very real there was a fight
that broke out I see the house and and
it was very you WWF oh man I mean me
watching I have fun seemed real enough I
mean they had priests Azadi come out
into the guy out and feel any different
name Aaron I know we can't have like an
open relationship kind of the gasps in
the room right now I really hope the
mics are picking them up just we kind of
have an open relationship for you I
think it's great I think it's the best
thing that anyone's ever did I came up
with the idea wonder like wait a second
you can be with somebody you are her
what a relationship oh I think it's
always yeah I think there's like mutual
type of thing so you broke through the
same I think we're I think we're in love
with each other like as like emotionally
I think it's less physical you remind me
you don't have an open related as a
video career but I think you're going
down a road that's like [__] like
and I don't mean this is an attack like
I think you're so [__] talented and I
look at you going down this Kardashian
male Kardashian row and I'm like oh man
you're so [__] talented like you're
some of the videos you've made in the
past I'm like I wish I was as good as
this dude like and he's [__] where
you at me like and now you're going down
this like chasing Fame row whether you
way though I've already got faith like
making videos with tan are you saying no
but like just a general like state of
mind of anything for publicity any
publicity is good publicity is like
really if you're Jake Paul like you've
got that now how about let's let's do
some great content because you are
[__] capable of that and I'm not
saying that as a con I'm saying that as
I I actually am a bit of a fan of what
you've done in the past not all of it
but I'm like you are [__] talented
oops and
yeah I just think you watch your videos
think this guy's killer like the best on
youtuber times even you are the wild
[__] when you were young and you
were driving a motorbike into a pool I
was like this guy I [__] like what
he's doing it was crazy
ya know I just saw what content
specifically are you saying like
somewhat an hour I feel like Gore has I
haven't been posting much recently
anyway went down the road which seemed
to be like oh okay for kids watching and
and you're getting old are in you're
like just you're growing out of that in
the fields like your force ninety
percent no so it's this weird transition
phase that I've gone through in like the
past four months where it was like I
stopped posting every other day there
was a point I was posting every other
day and I and and it took me a month
there was like a month period where I
was posting every other day and I was
like this like feels weird run like
still doing it because I'm so used to it
and I've been doing this for four years
now and I had to mentally be like wait I
don't like this this isn't me
I'm growing up and I have to like change
exactly what I'm doing and I explained
this on a recent podcast but you're
right it's like it was this Disney like
doing [__] for kids like doing clickbait
like you to be stuff just to get views
and I was like I had to realize like
your [__] this this isn't who I am
anymore and I think it's a weird thing
to go through and that it's the phase
that I'm that I'm like emerging out of
right now like being myself aging up
doing doing videos with like higher
quality content not just like you to be
[__] just to like get views what should
they do should go back on the dirt bikes
and [__] you think no no no it's not
like everyday J everyday bro let's do it
wasn't a video come on like to start the
video yeah I'll be like what the [__] is
this guy gonna do today like those a bit
of me no it's not I don't really watch
youtubers like that I was like I was
actually watching it actually says
nobody lies about it but today is
literally I actually watch the content
normally we walk in and go love your
stuff ya know but I just mean like back
in the day you are headed down a certain
Road and I feel like you've just gotten
sidetracked by I don't know maybe the
fame and all the rest of it but like you
don't have to chase that you're Jake
Paul now
everyone knows who the [__] you are I
think the side track that you think your
it is is is my strategy to age up it's
like things like it's like things like
being with Tana for example like I never
showed like my true personality and that
aged upside until it was on her Channel
and her friends like whoa we've never
seen this side of Jake wait oh my gosh I
actually like Jake like 20 22 year old
24 year olds being like you know this
kids like actually cool and then that
bit clicked in my head like why don't I
do this [__] on my channel and I think
it's because it was like Oh YouTube
Adsense like you're gonna get D monetize
and then I started realizing okay I
don't give a [__] I get do you monetize
anymore
it's like and then that's the phase I've
been in for the past five months like
making music aging up be like going
sucide tracking from like the Disney
Channel Jake Paula
I was so used by the way I like that
that was actually I also like I'm gonna
knock tower Weller out those are ready
but that was so awkward it was awkward
he punched or water all over and then he
was in the video I'm like oh my god
I asked him how he got Joe Weller to be
in his own district it didn't make sense
to me it was that before you knocked him
out after it was after he voluntarily
did it Joe's like I love Joe I think
there's a pot you know when you talk
about accepting whatever's happened and
just owning it yeah just did that at
that time but I just don't think it was
the right move I've been a fan of Joe
for a minute ever since he did the WWE
into the period like he's one of our our
most talented guys over here for sure
yeah what what is going on so you're
gonna with Donna is just this the real
deal is that do you think getting
married like made you see outside of the
circle that you had like you like you
you looked outside of your immediate
people and you were like oh this is how
other people see me maybe I need to go
more down that yeah he didn't take the
easy path which was start a podcast you
know what I'm saying like that was the
that was the best thing this kid ever
did you know I'm saying it took him out
of the realm of you know good morning
low gang what's poppin and that and that
side of him that people were like who
the [__] is this kid why did why does he
always have that personality on and sat
him down and give him two hours a day to
talk about who he really is and real
[__] and cultural [__] and in the news
[__] and so like that wasn't the right
fit for Jake but I think that that was
that was what allowed Logan to go and
age himself up was was impulsive you
know this is the most important sentence
I'll say today I think people
underestimate the power of routines and
when you're caught in a routine of daily
vlogging or like going on a Disney show
every day is for me anecdotally daily
vlogging was the thing that made me
become this you know exaggerated version
of Logan Paul which is why when I say
sometimes when I get hyped that that
comes out because it's so easy for me to
go there because it's what I knew and
every day you know five to seven million
views and people like this like oh it's
skewed as a much young younger audience
but trying to come out of that routine
of like the vlog character and then
adapt it into the podcast which is what
I've done has been such a blessing for
me because again being able to talk at
length and like articulate my thoughts
not like a [__] is the greatest thing
ever
it has forced me to evolve as a human in
my personal life because I can do that
now you made a [__] great decision
when you picked a real dude like him how
did you meet him and why did you pick
him it's the weirdest thing ever this is
so weird
I heard about these giant bean bags
called love sacks these giant bean bags
called love sacks and I knew I had to
have one so I went into the store and
I'm like hey like I do social media is
there any way I could like get in
contact with someone like I may be doing
a post in exchange for a bean bag that
is expensive like fifty hundred bucks
left side and this is what I was doing
vine so like I had some money but I'd
rather do a post they got me in contact
with the marketing manager or whatever
some dude named Mike so I started
texting this dude and like I liked it I
like to test people like gauge gauge him
a little bit like their personalities
and whatnot he seemed like funny on text
so he sent me the love sack and I was
like hey these are great by the way like
can you [__] him though
and he sent me a text back like actually
you can they're machine washable so get
your common buddy yeah you'll actually
come right off I gonna come right out of
I was like this guy's great
I was started we started with that and
then after that we did a couple like
like excursions together we did Sundance
yeah I remember Sundance that's the
first moment I met you you walked into
my room I think well has changed you
guys just started you did not have a
good first means you had a horrible
first meeting do you remember that yeah
he was it his house is Sunday when I was
him and the the two twins that he abused
what were they
the more you know and this was that no
this was at the height of his like
that's why he was beating up all the
kids beating up all the kids with the
complete so and I was like yo what's up
man I'm Mike good to meet you and he was
like yeah whatever whatever and
something happened oh I told you a good
trail that I found at that I skied that
day and you were like do you even
[__] live here bro that was so close
I go no I don't live here but I skied
today and I was just like so bad yes I
poached Mike from loveSac and now he's
on the number one podcast the world is
my roommate yeah he's a great guy you
got a [__] interested playing I
thought like there's a lot of things
that people don't know about you yeah
yeah you put bottles with drugs yeah
yeah man I was I was in I was in the
[__] for 10 years but I was I was living
on the streets bro like living on
people's couches I slept in trunks of
cars like I've seen a lot of [__] been
on [__] operating tables 5-6 times
like almost died a bunch of times and
and buried a lot of good friends and
been through the court systems been
through the jails so like all that [__]
you know what I'm saying so if there's a
hell of a story though consider I got a
book coming out a book coming out in
January the whole the whole thing it's a
quote it's gonna it's called don't say
I'll suit soon enough about we're gonna
keep an eye out for the off thing I got
to do a podcast with just you and I find
a nice boring people people who are as
cool as Mike and as specialized Mike is
as a human like again I'll refer to him
as like a unicorn like a real one of one
type guy so [__] funny dude as
opposed to like what some other [__]
some things where you're like Chloe
[__] Bennett she has my gem of
someone I can you go like oh yeah
so so because of the immense amount of
adversity that mike has gone through
that's the reason he is the way he is
and he is such like a likable guy
to 99% of people but he's been through
so much [__] and he's come out
victorious like he should have died like
10 times and he's being like humble
right now but this book is gonna be
personally I can't wait to wait to read
it like I'm Mike's biggest fan have you
seen the night shift
you know she shows it's the greatest
program on you train I'm sure this
show's gonna come you get all the Pawn
Stars bro this is pissing me off on
jealousy because I just went that way
with it you know what I'm saying like we
live we live and we live in LA like
these dudes have [__] cash they're
good-looking dudes like they could have
gone that way too they just chose not to
they're good kids like hi what does the
cash have to do they would I mean bro
you get you get you clout clouds all you
need something whatever the case we had
we had Riley on the podcast oh yeah and
as soon as that happened it's set off
for me being an addict a chain reaction
of the desire to [__] every porn star
that exists in the [__] world and I'm
doing critic and I'm doing pretty
[__] good pretty well guy tells me
stories all the time I'm like bro you're
like a little kid again
literally bro I feel like a little kid
in a candy store I showed him a video
too
well yo but it's but honestly like for
me it has potential just becoming
another vice for me you know what I'm
saying because like you know that world
is just as [__] it can be just as
dark and scary as as as drugs you know
being would you be an opponent um
I've talked about it beyond July I've
talked about it being a fallback and
I've definitely shot my share because so
not like against it but but right now
the direction of of where I'm going with
like the book with impulsive with the
nightshift with all the things that are
going on I don't think that I'm gonna be
doing any Adam 22 times you talking
about bronze a lot on Twitter you seen
business savvy you see them be switched
off yeah oh yeah of course I mean the
reason the reason I joined Logan to
begin with was to be part of his
business team and so I joined on to help
recover maverick
and then bring maverick back to a place
where it was in the trajectory that it
was in prior to Tokyo and so some of
those things that me and him enacted
right as soon as I started was a review
process he should have had a review
process prior to Tokyo if he had a team
around him at the time that was paying
attention to [__] that video never would
have gone out so the first thing I did
when I got there I said we got to set up
a review team and now we have a review
team do we need it anymore no because
he's gotten a lot smarter and a lot
wiser and a lot you know more educated
but I base everything that I do in
business because I have a long
background of business history and so
that's what I was originally supposed to
do and then as soon as I joined the team
we started a podcast
he was like want to sit in on the
podcast and we sat down like you know
it's the best [__] thing that's ever
happened that's the greatest so number
one podcast in the world I couldn't I
mean it's available well let your help
depends where you're on stats analytics
you can't debate it we can we talk can
we talk about this person because I
think this is the most interesting thing
in the world it's a number one podcast
it's not though okay Jules and shits on
you from a good you're not even Joe and
Joe Joe Logan Paul George is rockin he
is Joe Morgan listen Logan poem session
I think this is a bigger to shake your
core question is what is your metric for
success okay I've got one okay if the
metric is stupid things such as
viewership money those kind of things
yes respect what I'm joking then maybe
yes show Rogan is the number one podcast
in the world in terms of view ability
look over it looks porn star facts but
you know I don't know it just depends on
what you're metric is like why here's
what we're doing bro
the majority of 16 to 20 yeah a 24 year
olds [__] at a high time with me I
won't 8:28 I was gonna say that I went
24 2016 2 28 year olds I would argue the
majority of them are not consuming
podcasts as the content that they like
to digest we do a good job of bridging
the gap the liaison between
listenable digested
content in Pocket in audio form because
it's not as fun as video and actual
value and we try to bridge that gap make
it fun but provide education edutainment
I agree with you Geordi and - I look
like Cayman is a [__] word though
dude you've got a bit hold on a second
we brought we brought Riley on the show
one of our most viewed episodes that
episode was very fun nonnative not it
was informative right not long
thereafter we brought Alex Jones on the
show not long after Ben Shapiro on the
show and so we walk a very very funny
hair and when I went and by the way when
everybody else asked Shapiro what are
the core differences right now between
the left and right how are we gonna
solve it I've heard that answer 40,000
times I want to know what [__]
cereal he eats at night it's gorgeous
it's chrisfix yeah could a guest on the
other day the versatility of our podcast
is unparalleled
that cannot be that cannot be matched
ask you question go yeah for my own
selfish reasons why don't you stroke my
ego a little bit do you think I'm the
most versatile entertainer on our planet
Wow you clearly never seen Robbie
Williams you're versatile you are
versatile I'm versatile as well so I'm
sorry you think yourself you already
know nobody I don't I don't know I don't
have the advantages you've got but I've
done alright in the UK I mean I'm pretty
playing the race card yeah I don't know
this is why yeah it's a really good
point who's the best guest you guys have
ever had on like in terms of great
question yeah that's why I asked it I
like this guy oh you guys I had an
answer I really loved both Eric Griffin
and Andrew Shoals the comedians that guy
is so funny he is
he is amazing and it's they don't
necessarily pull in the most views
because it's not like a YouTube centric
like click Beatty title but I mean
comedians are incredible to have on your
podcast talk about just a good good
old-fashioned template in life all the
time to try and find the funny in it so
they're actually thinking about what the
[__] is going on well and there's so
much there's so much overlap with the
conversation that they bring to the
table right now because canceled culture
is so [__] hot right now especially in
LA and so when they come to talk about
canceled culture they're talking to
someone that was more involved in that
culture than anyone else and so the
overlap there is is instantaneous and
really like palpable question for as a
podcaster though yo you're constantly
trying to find the juiciest conversation
on a daily basis almost you're trying to
make interesting conversations happen do
you know when you're not doing that and
you're just shooting the [__] with like
regular people do you find it more
boring than before I'm never I'm never
bored I'm that if me if me and him are
in the car together I mean when you're
just talking a regular power and you're
not on hand so you're not interviewing
all these interesting people and you're
not driving the conversation to make it
the most interesting and you're just
shooting the [__] with some average
George you're saying it's all good
you're saying in real life yeah do you
ever find this all just going god I was
doing something so much more enjoy one
has up to 60 seconds to captivate me and
if they're not I'm not giving you my
energy I'm just not okay like this [__]
is too precious your energies your
currency dude and if I find a
conversation is draining me like
especially now like in flight mode I'm
out wow that's harsh on an uber driver
though isn't it if I'm in an uber I'll
give you 60 seconds but after that like
I need to get to work I need I put in my
ear pods and I'm on I'm doing emails
like I'm just uh I'm just at that point
where like low key no new friends dude
like I got a circle and I'm not really
interested in trying to I agree I've
mastered the end of mastered and in
conversation okay who's that - oh I hate
small talk oh great
alright look that's actually just what
he holds up to the driver obviously with
all the controversy you've been through
to me with the views that you guys are
pulling in with the names you have you
should have brands [__] all over you
what
what are the big other big brands [__]
with you yet like because to me you're
about a fight in one of the most watched
fights in the in the calendar year in
psi the last fight was huge
oh you know Nike Adidas cause of all the
[__] that's gone on are they interested
in you yeah there's a there's a couple
answers to this question I want to break
it down so one is yes some some big
brands are interested in working with us
too or a bit hesitant sometimes because
if it's not organic I won't do it
I don't I don't I'm not I'm not feigning
for money I don't I don't necessarily
need that that bag and you've seen the
folks list that's I'm saying so if I'm
if I'm not working with a brand that I
don't need to I'm not gonna do it and
and I think third building your own
brand ie maverick for me specifically is
so much cooler than selling out to Nike
or that's adidas that's what you're just
seeing it at the macro level in LA right
now Brande Brande are like mid-level and
below every big influencer right now is
building a brand is building a brand
that they can somehow monetize whether
it's through it was those makeup guys me
I feel like I [__] up in if you're
jeffree star so if you're James Charles
yeah yeah I mean you made it yeah well
mainly Geoffrey though because like
James didn't build his own brand what
about the makeup palettes that's not his
brand he gets he gets private shares but
you know the literal cuz I wanted one I
wish I try to get a Jinni charles pal
you just commentary no not back in
equity though Jeffrey Jeffrey bill his
own brand
cuz he's gonna sell he's gonna sell it
for a billion dollar you know what you
know what's cool you know it's you know
super cool million dollar brand deal you
know it's you know it's super cool or we
are making 50 million dollars on a brand
that's cool selling your own [__] which
by the way he did in 2017 it was
clothing and then everybody and then for
2017 2018 everybody's like how do we do
clothing but then the clothing like has
anybody done anything even close I've
seen I know like all the influencers
numbers in this now
close it's like it's like we were the
wave of clothing in 2017 or 2018 and
then all the other influencers were like
oh I want to sell much now I'm late and
that's what we've seen in 2019 and it's
like bro we've sold a t-shirt to
probably every kid on YouTube that's a
thing Time Lords to announce that I want
you miss out very soon
it's in the description below I mean
listen for your core fans it's still
fine it's great still got to promote the
show but like do we is that number from
2017 pulp I mean we talk about it don't
we
let it be known let it be that's very
high say it's public it he did he did 35
millions in merch sales in 17
no cash 35 million dollars so I mean and
saying that's and that's just clothing I
also believe this though although it was
merch to be a maverick and that symbol M
means so much to people and I know it
can be perceived this corny or cheesy
but that symbol and the the idea of
being independent and using your
differences to make you stand out and
succeed is so true to me and apparently
it resonates with a lot of other people
as well so I'm actually gonna revive
this brand I have a strategy but I think
we gonna do like a slight rewrite
rebranding and 6 and fuel back in the
tank because you know I think you think
so man
as a youtuber who's tried to do the same
[__] so I look at what you did then I
was like [__] me that's amazing yeah me
I grew up on the [__] like Council of
state in the UK like I don't know what
he caught the projects all of you okay I
come from I come from nothing so here
that is possible from uploading [__]
videos to YouTube it blows my [__]
mind so if any of us can make that kind
of money
I even closer then go for it and also
Marvin anything I want like my logo I
like the actual that what you provide do
you know I'm taking note where was your
main sales from like what country will
you at us there's there's a lotta
there's a lot of global sales as well
Canada UK he wanted to buy or whatever
and these [__] kids what mental
wasn't even available in Dubai they'd
ship it to the border of I think and
then they get it shipped in from there
I've had issues with like a bunch yeah a
lot of a lot
these countries can what do you worry
about what do you think about the
ability for that brand to continue now
that whoa no because what happened well
we said well there was an incident in
January that kind of like oh no so no
he's talking about something else I was
nine uh maverick the bird has the map
made well I mean like if anything it
just makes it more like everlasting then
isn't it because it's like you're
literally playing tribute to this pay
yeah I just think I got out I want to
get creative with the strategy on what
we do to make this brand once again one
of the biggest influencer brands in the
world and then hopefully transcend that
so it's no longer an influencer brand
like my goal is to have this be like in
in in ten to twenty years like a Nike or
adidas like an athleisure signed
athletes high production commercials all
that [__] you you would never believe
like how close he wants that like like
like I mean like dude like yo he was he
was literally like cry like six six to
twelve months away from my attorney into
a multi Multi multi hundred million
dollar company
like like money on the table all the
investment in place myself real good at
now no but it's not like you're sitting
there holding and that's what and that's
why when people are whenever it was like
me people that are still talking about
yes said that [__] me zoo rivers I just
get looped into every absolutely
was there a bit say that terrible what
do you say that what I had a girl that I
was in the hot tub look at the other
time he [__] a and she goes yeah I mean
I'm trying to think of any way to say
this on I'm like a live format but
they're like yeah like I had someone I'm
very close with had some some business
problems with Logan and I was like I'm
pretty in tune with his business I'm not
aware of any issues that were going on
they're like yeah man it was it was
pretty bad and I was like are you sure
it was Logan and then they're like yeah
I think so the the blonde one and I was
like ah see there's actually two there's
actually two of them and so like we
actually like the over here like there
are a lot of people that are less likely
to call it Logan or Jake
and they dirts like that Logan and Jay
Paul know Paul's yeah yeah you know you
know on the way out did you do all the
do Toxie get attacked cuz I was did real
yours got a so we thought we were you
I'm good in the back in this kid
shouting it's Logan Paul and where every
to give me a perspective of what it's
like to be you yeah smooth sailing the
windows right like that we won't look at
decoy here so we're coming out
originally when people see you know
scary and they're like oh dude like oh
and then next thing you know like as it
gets further away from the entrance and
as they realize like people forget who
was in and the next floor to people
don't know who's in bro oh it's Logan
see I don't understand cuz like I'm here
to tell you like guys like I'm your me
um I'm your I'm your friend
please don't definitely pump the crowd
but don't hit my car don't have my cars
and stuff like after I be JJ I don't
want people to be angry at me like I
wanted I want to take the audience
that's watching JJ fight and supporting
JJ with me when I do my next fight
potentially in the UFC like sure
well I know but this butcher oh no I'm
serious bro like would ya ya know
because I hear this a lot and I think
myself all right stand obscured you can
wrestle and I'll be watching you see
since day one and they've given fire
fights to say I'm Punk who like you know
had no business bein anywhere near a
cage so you that you could do it but
it's whether or not what is in it for
you because they're not gonna pay the
money that's gonna actually like mean
anything to you I don't believe that I
bet I could get Dana to move that chili
I think so yeah I think Brock broke what
is it when you imagine this is a
scenario where I want if I were to ever
get a secure a fight in the UFC a stage
that big and has that much brand
recognition my build-your-own
be my prowess as a influencer I think I
would have the potential and the power
to rally the entire community that
watches people online not just Logan
Paul fans like if you notice when
creators do things that are great
creators internet-based people they do
things that are great PewDiePie for
example any hits 100 million everyone on
YouTube supports PewDiePie every every
creator every person watching and so I
believe if I fought in the UFC not only
would I bring my fans but everyone who
just wants to support the kid who whose
platform was built by you know I think
you massive there's no doubt about that
just didn't USA Europe it you know I
mean whether or not there and also you
need a dance partner you need someone
who's willing to get in there who has a
profile of their own who was limited
experience who's actually a good match
for you that's gonna be really difficult
that's the tricky Dancing with the Stars
would be easier I don't want that I
don't want that to happen like I'm fully
I'm a completely against him doing MMA
or you should go down the entertainment
road no here's why as we see her at this
table right now is there any part of you
who feels like and this is not a slight
it's just a question like Logan Paul is
going to be xx class champion of the
world champion of the world or or hear
me out or MMA champion of the world
answer the question started training
boxing guys from this table I think I
put this table to the test we should be
alright I've done things on this table
before worse than this so we should be
good power smashed on the table already
enjoy my definitely call get on this
Logan
I look Juno is I said no he should be my
open and exactly yeah okay I feel like
you do it at MMA now see I'm still here
so yeah so let me before you even answer
let me let me just say why ask it the
reason I ask is he in the past and
through now he is proven in the world
that he is one of the best if not the
best creator in the world okay you
usually do that when I talk about myself
well like let me let me finish well let
me finish I am no I'll my bro I love I
mean finish the [__] thought I love
you clean listen one of the best writers
you get someone on my team we like to
gasses me up this put anybody on the go
would anybody argue that that he's my
daddy years has proved that he's one of
the best storytellers or content
creators in the world and my big iam
uppers no no we gotta clean he's proven
his point one okay okay yeah fact why
would you walk away from something you
were going a lot farther with that
statement
alright you went you went like super
high and they're gonna down a little bit
more I'm a [__] nobody
oh alright alright you're my right-hand
man your bit more than that thank you
because if you're a nobody what am i
right time bar true a lighting I think
our capability to be there but I think
on YouTube we tend to think within our
bubble and I think a Netflix or someone
like that would look at some of our
content and go with the [__] is it these
you have it I think your capability of
being able to go to a Netflix and go I
could do this so it's that I see that
potential but I'm not seeing like
[__] David Fincher and you're in your
daily videos do you know what I mean but
it's not that I don't think you're
capable of that at one point I'm gonna
step back even further because him is it
worth say he was the best crater and he
we just say that he has the ability to
do it again cuz in 2017 he was getting
[__] 250 million views on videos good
at this okay
these are facts I'm not begging anybody
[__] eyes now listen why would he
walk away from the potential to do that
to go get his be destroyed appointment
why shouldn't some amends there's this
thing isn't it yeah in some men there's
this thing where I want to be great it's
not about the money it's it's it's this
ego thing that we don't have that know
what I mean no I don't have that no but
I'm just saying if you did that would be
why you'd walk away so why would you do
it then what is it about the UFC what
are you getting out or boxing more you
know do you know do you know what my
goal is have you heard me say has anyone
heard me say I have is to be the biggest
entertainer in the world Thanks all
right what does that mean that means
some hooker rock it rise why why is he
great right no you're talking about all
right these movies are terrible we all
know that means in terms of the biggest
entertainer in the world from an
aesthetic standpoint wrestling days he's
done pretty much everything and let's be
honest see if the UFC had been a thing
when he was in his prime he probably
would have [__] done that as well he
would've just said it so you're trying
to be the one who does everything I get
that and I read everything the boxing in
MMA but our outliers the rock did
wrestling okay these are outliers I'm
just because when you I'm saying the
biggest so sure let's use the rock as an
example but like and [__] roast me if
you feel like it but like my goal is to
be bigger than the rock and I mean that
raw I'm 24 years old
do you know how much time I have so if I
do a sick stint as a professional
fighter that I can do because I you know
I work hard
athletically blessed and willing to put
in the mental energy to do that and I
can become the best creator on YouTube
again these are these are my goals like
these are the things I want to do should
I fail God strike me down but I'm gonna
do the best that I can to make all these
things but the music director Zac Efron
huge actor right yeah say he said I want
to be the biggest entertainer in the
world and he said so I'm gonna go into
shark diving or by the way I'm gonna go
into [__] I'm gonna go in
battle I'm gonna go I'm gonna go into
the Marines I'm gonna go into the
Marines because I want to be and GoPro
it and there are outliers to what you
will do in another genre because they
will [__] you in another if you have no
brain because your head gets pummeled in
we can't have the best podcast you can't
be an actor you can't be a comedian a
singer nothing you will just be a
[__] potato Sara single I think about
what is the cost is there a signal that
you out of all of these things that you
tried to do in the past that you're more
drawn to one thing it's unfortunately
combat sports really it's unfortunately
combat Wichita dog yo in high school in
high school I wanted to do MMA for a
living and then I and then I was like
[__] I'm I'm like way too smart for this
like Brahma smart kid and I and I and I
realized like I kind of liked studying
and putting my mind to work and I could
probably make more money and get more
done and accomplish more if I use my
mind instead of my fists and that's what
happened and now somehow I got sucked
back into the [__] and I'm like [__] I
like it I like getting hit and that's
like if he likes if he loves it and he
liking cuz by the way what the [__] does
my opinion matter on a hill but like but
but still if he told me he's like yo
this is what I love to do and I want to
be the best fighter in the world then
I'll be like yo then [__] do it but
like when it's like y'all want to be the
most versatile entertainer in the world
you're talking about doing something
that could [__] you in every other arena
because you have no head left this why
he's my guy you had you have Brendan
Schaub on your podcast shut up Brendan
shop brand shops the [__] guy but he
quit the EOC for that reason he didn't
want to have the concussions he didn't
want to be slow in his speech he's a
comedian and he does everything bit like
you got kids you know yeah are you
looking at that and being like maybe I
should learn from this guy not no no III
I do and I am learning from Brendan and
every other fighter who I've seen
there's harm in one fight step down
prematurely yeah for sure there's no
there's no there's no harm in one fight
Mike saw what it would say for you you
wouldn't fight to prove the point me
because once you do that one if you
smoke a guy and everyone's chanting your
name and you know it's off there you can
logon Paul top of the [__] races then
cuz the addiction it's gonna grow in the
one for it's all gonna happen then and
you want I know I've played this
scenario out my head I'm with end which
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do my first year
I'm a BJJ I'm gonna do my first fight in
the UFC I'm gonna win I'm gonna smoke
this [__] dude whoever it is and then
there's gonna be I'm gonna be like yo yo
I think I'm good
that was fun and then I'm gonna get a
huge bag place in front of me and I'm
gonna be like Brock could use another
roll add another Rolex at that point
like you know he was talking about the
other day came up in conversation with
with the crew at the house vine Island
about Patek the potential of Logan Paul
Kohner burger yeah Jeffery Epstein's
islands are for sale yeah and you'd also
have to put up with all the go yo I'm a
Gregor may well McGregor's knowing I
mean this is just like three different
weight classes away I mean you're like
the only way you're with McGregor is you
create a whisky cuz there's no way he's
gonna know you're a massive mark do you
hear this McGregor is tiny compared to
you that's not even what that's that's
that's the theory that's why like I'm
sure he'd uh he'd probably kill me but
the reason it's maybe okay in any
capacity is that his level of combat
ability is so much high she never you
know what though yeah and this guy's got
one or two fights up and he's done like
he's getting out because he sees
whatever means I yeah oh yeah he's gonna
resurrect maverick so who have you
actually fought recently that you're
scared of because Oregon a huge part of
it to me seems like you're not actually
you've you've not actually I don't say
not scary JJ you've not had an opponent
recently who's maybe scared you away
from fighting or made you consider it
who have you fought that you're actually
like [__]
Burrell look like a [__] to you know
but you can still be scared you know
most people who get the better of you on
a sparring must be I I knew I know for a
fact that Shannon Briggs would be doing
his job unless he was putting you over
people who are [__] really roughing
you up at times so I think the point
stands is it are you feeling like you're
getting pushed to the limit right now
I don't know if pushing yourself to the
limit is healthy okay because sometimes
when you're at your limit you break okay
you know I don't want to I don't want to
over train or for no reason spar some
professional boxer who by the way would
[__] kill me yeah and hurt me when we
don't know if this is the path I'm gonna
take for the rest of my life well your
question but as far as like being scared
goes I mean this I'm not trying to
[__] flaunt my dick size maybe it's
because like the haters say it's cause
like I'm too dumb but like there is a
piece of my brain missing that
recognizes in clocks fear I it's it's
next to nothing dude
like I remember when I went skydiving I
got my skydiving license and my second
solo jump do you guys remember this my
second solo job my main parachute did
not open my main parachute was stuck for
10 seconds and I'm like sick I have one
reserve chute and by the way I hope it
[__] opens and the one thing I
remember about that experience that I'll
never forget is the calm that I felt in
that if I don't take these necessary
steps right now I'm gonna [__] die I
trusted myself there was no fear like
there was no like oh it's just like
y'all I need to do what I need to do to
live Baba look red grab red peel pool
look silver grab silver pupil Reserve
opens ten twists I'm in the air like
this wow I hope I get untwist it in time
before I hit the ground just spinning
spinning spinning so yeah bruh I don't I
don't fear unfortunately is not a thing
that maybe for better or worse uh
answers my brain do you know when you
came out against JJ yeah I was I mean
obviously in the first round it was cool
it was quite clear that you weren't that
scared are you weren't nervous and
unshot me but before you came out before
the music played and all of that do you
even have the other butterflies did you
I know I'm trying to put myself in the
shoes there I want to say a little while
ago I want to say yes because it seemed
it's that seems way abnormal 20,000
people booing you like if I had a lot of
admiration for you getting in there I'm
like yeah you as well
I'm like [__] me these guys are getting
in there getting boot I I'm a [__]
hard man but I probably would have been
like [__] you know the world as well
like it's not either at home do you know
what I mean that wasn't that wasn't fun
that shit's ours the hardest thing for
all of us that was the hardest thing for
me was I would be out hit dad she hit
dad she hit dad she hard hits hard hits
jab boom jab boom and then he goes like
this and the crowd was like oh goes he
goes like this
Oh like that was the hardest thing for
me to deal with ologies affair the
commentary didn't reflect them way out
of place here but I thought the the
people who were supporting Jake and I
were I was actually surprised about how
many of them were looking back now and
seeing that ratio now compared to then
now I'm even most surprised at how many
people with that sort of like love you
guys hmm wait we wait till you come to
LA I think we're like 5,000 fans with
her right maybe a little bit I don't
know but yeah as far as like anxiety or
nerves I may have just been to uh to
focus to really clock it or let it
affect me and I've also like probably
been on stages like of that amount
before like bro I was one of the best
wrestlers in the state of Ohio they
filled the Ohio State arena and is that
why time I made for you because you know
you can wrestle this is half a fight
yeah when I I thought I could challenge
JJ to do MMA when he when he called me
out for boxing I don't really have any
leverage because he had just one but
yeah I would love to do to get in the
Octagon do that I love wrestling go I
love I loved you Jitsu and submissions
and I can't do any of that so when we
when we last seeing you you were and I
mean this is I was impressed with your
job but you could tell there wasn't that
much more to you as a fight I like you
had a great job but and you're you could
judge him coming in but there wasn't
that much more because you Jake said to
me you'd only just kind of clocked on to
what boxing was what is your game now in
terms of without revealing everything
obviously do you feel like you're
learning a lot more and you've you've
gone through that yeah man it's not even
comparable like there it's night it's
night and day quite literally what like
the reason we brought Shannon Briggs in
is because you said it like I'm a big
guy
mm-hmm I have a lot of muscle yeah
there's no reason I shouldn't be
knocking that people out in the first or
second round which is Shannon specialty
oh [__]
one of the few people who when I'm
around him I'm like I hope this guy
doesn't [__] yo yo wait to see it we all
wait to in practice when he's showing
you how to do a move on you yeah and
he's just flicking his jab out and by
the way I don't have you felt his
fingers yeah her his fingers are like
cement little bricks all of them grow
and they hurt just his fingers out it
he's a bad man and something nobody's
talking about is that home is that home
turf advantage you know what I'm saying
I mean like that all that [__] that
happened last fight was him undertrained
him in another in a foreign country just
all dremel and it's all that adrenaline
this dudes walking into the Staples
Center that is our [__] City the
reason I wear the LA there's a reason I
wear the LA hat all the time that is our
[__] City we run that city like that
dude is walking into the to the Lions
Den in front of one of the biggest
[__] crowds in one of the most
important in front of a lot of
celebrities do I think yes I was gonna
be like oh my god like that celebrity
[__] is every day for him every single
day for him you know what I'm saying
like he he talks to Bieber he talks to
those people those are his friends what
what is Justin Bieber actually like such
a wimp what's he like what does he like
yeah he's dope yeah he's dope it's been
a minute since we've hung out in person
but I mean he's cool as [__] he's I mean
he's my age he's uh he's a kid who wants
to live a normal kid's life but happened
to have the talent to become or the
biggest superstars in the world yeah
he's great
I seen him on a roast once where people
are trying oh my god yes I've read a 200
million in all these people all these
husbands are calling me a lesbian some
reason we just watch that today right oh
he's he's amazing he's uh he's in my
corner he wants to come to the fight
okay I'm gonna give him get him four
tickets and so you're coming out
obviously right I haven't be nice to
each other
by who were asking you right now what do
I don't think Eddie Hearn actually like
knew a lot about me before the night
falls I got this did you talk to him I
was wondering how you got this I was
wondering who would host them so it
seems like someone suggested to them
like you're you're just sitting there
and Latin look and j-just go out there
in shock Eddie I didn't look great I
need to get true Jordi and he was
probably like huh I'm gonna I'm gonna I
want to put in the word I would love for
you to to commentate it actually I mean
even if it's not you should you have to
be going there yeah I remember I
remember this all I wanted sorry I
shouted finish him I didn't mean it but
yeah we I I don't know they don't know
they've not said anything to me but
actually I'm like whatever like you know
no because you know what I like about
this is that there are there's merit in
the roots that all this was born from
and you you're not been here since the
joella's first fight like the Joella
fight with his best friend Theo I
commented that I can't I'm saying
there's something so swell do you know
what I mean it might be time for another
yes Brent up great yeah TV guys come in
and I got the big boys ago I don't want
them to we saw the TV guys we the TV
guys are if you guys saw the challenger
games who saw me commentate next to a TV
guy because I it's hardness is on screen
Brian was distracting the but we don't
have her in England realistic well it's
not that I was looking but Brian was
very much like engrossed in this feed
either so I went that's what I realized
that me and Mike we should we well yeah
well first of all we got to go we got to
go to dinner y'all should link him yeah
get to the [__] stage to the fight we
won't we won't be able to do impulsive
because we're on break up until the
fight but we should do something make
sure you're there get get to the fight
Joe each member 9th at the Staples
Center if you live in LA or any of the
surrounding areas I want to see you
there or if they I watch it's gonna be
on the disease
app downloaded get ready to watch me
[__] what's the staple center like like
if you guys big clippers or Laker sons
like do you go regularly I was there on
the floor - giant I went there for
awesome awesome charity best my aim was
great yeah yeah you were just being
supportive I'm not I'm not great at
basketball that's how I pulled my
hamstring yeah I have regarding Snoop
Dogg playing basketball is your hump
sure y'all don't really like fully cool
got lucky got real lucky because uh I
don't think the zone assign a contract
they knew I couldn't walk in Ibiza I'm
good now or should we wrap this up zoom
out so yeah he's taking them to dinner a
big thumbs mr. Logan Jake Mike all good
guys appreciate your time don't forget
to check out everything they're doing
and watch the fight Logan Paul care site
November 9th thanks for watching
subscribe we'll see as they are